hello in this video we'll talk about
ionotropic and metabotropic receptors
these receptors are two type of
receptors which are found in membranes
which are involved in transport and
signal transduction let's talk about the
ionotropic receptors first ionotropic
receptors are ligand-gated ion channels
which are made up of
three four or five subunits
generally they are heteromars that means
all these subunits are different from
each other's now they have two broad
structural features
one is the ligand binding domain which
is present in the extracellular surface
and it binds to the ligand
and the next one is the transmembrane
domain which actually forms the iron
conducting pore
for simplicity we will describe the
ionotropic receptors
by these kind of cartoons
here we have isotropic receptors in two
different configurations
based on the presence or absence of the
ligand
so this is the ionotropic receptor when
the ligand is absent in this situation
the gate of these ionotropic receptors
is closed
and therefore the ions cannot pass
through this channel
now imagine there would be
the ligand
which would bind to the extracellular
domain of these ionotropic receptors
this leads to a conformational change
in the gate and now the gate is open
which would allow the diffusion or the
passing of these
ions through these pores
and that is how ionotropic receptors
work
so so we kind of simplified the mode of
action
but the question is where we can find
ionotropic receptors
they can be found in many locations one
common location is the synapse of the
neurons in the synapses ionotropic
receptors are generally found on the
postsynaptic membrane where they bind to
neurotransmitters and allows cation
influx in the postsynaptic membrane
other than that we can find them in
neuromuscular junction stomach and the
lining of gastrointestinal tract
for example in parietal cells of the
stomach we can find
ligand-gated ion channels as well
now let's talk about a synapse and try
to understand the functionality of the
ligand-gated ion channels when the
presynaptic action potential reach the
synapse it would lead
to
neurotransmitter release this
neurotransmitter
neurotransmitters work like a ligand for
the ligand-gated ion channels present on
the postsynaptic membrane
now
these
neurotransmitters would bind to the
ligand binding cleft
this would allow a conformational change
in these ionotropic receptors
which further allows ions in this case
cations
to pass through this channel
when cations pass through and get inside
the postsynaptic membrane it would
create a positive charge inside the
membrane it would
change the membrane potential to be more
positive
and that allows a wave of depolarization
in the postsynaptic membrane and that's
how
the electrical impulses pass through the
neurons and pass through the synapses
now
there could be
ionotropic receptors which allow the
passage of cations there could be also
ionotropic receptors which allows
passage of anions like the gaba
receptors present in the
many many type of neurons in our nervous
system
now let's talk about metabotropic
receptors metabotropic receptors can be
also found in our nervous system and
they are generally found in olfactory
sensory neurons out of many examples
so in the olfactory sensory neurons we
can found find these metabotropic
receptors which are g protein coupled
receptors
so they binds to odor molecules which
leads to a conformational change
and that allows gtp exchange in the
trimeric g protein associated with this
receptor
this gtp bound g protein would
eventually activate
adenylate cyclase adenylate cyclase is
an enzyme which converts atp into cyclic
amp
now on the membrane of olfactory sensory
neurons we have ligand-gated ion
channels which are activated by cyclic
amp so cyclic amp
is actually binding to these ion
channels and allowing
passage of ions through them
so here the ion channel is not directly
bound to a extracellular
ligand
but the ligand binds to a different
receptor which leads to a cascade of
events ultimately allowing up ion
channel to open
so this is how metabotropic receptors
function
structural differences can be
appreciated at this point but let's talk
about some functional differences
receptors are really rapid and their
responses are fast this lasts for
fractions of milliseconds whereas
metabotropic receptors are relatively
slow their response kinetics vary from
several milliseconds to even seconds so
now we can appreciate the differences
and similarities between the
uh ionotropic and metabotropic receptors
we can also appreciate where they are
situated
especially in our nervous system so i
hope this video was useful if you like
this video give it a big thumbs up
so you can support my channel via
patreon or if you are a indian viewer
you can support me via bimupi app
my courses are also present in an
academy you can use my code ap 10 to get
a 10 discount as usual don't forget to
like share and subscribe do let me know
in the comments how you like my video if
you have a suggestion please put it in
the comment thank you see you next video